[Music]
foreign
do you feel like we need to abolish
capitalism in time yes how do we do that
and what comes after I'd like to see it
become like a Star Trek Utopia you know
that's just that's just me
hello people I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report it's September 13
2023 and this is the part of the show
that I normally tell you to subscribe on
Rumble locals and YouTube but yesterday
we noticed that our our audio podcast is
absolutely blowing up and I never
promoted I don't put the links anywhere
I never tell you to do it yet many of
you are listening I always think
everyone's watching a lot of you are
listening so if you have not uh and
you'd like to please subscribe on Apple
podcast on Spotify or wherever you get
your audio Pleasures on that note we
will be doing a post game show as always
at reubenreport.locals.com and the theme
today is that the whole damn thing seems
like it's melting down but if you've
been paying attention for a couple years
they've been telling us exactly what is
going to happen and it's exactly what's
happening right now we're gonna go
backwards a little bit uh to one of the
things that I missed when I was off the
grid in August which is the massive
disaster the horrific fire that occurred
in Maui in Hawaii and we're going to
talk a little bit about the Biden
Administration reaction to that and I'm
going to link that to some of the other
things happening with the administration
right now and you just kind of Wonder
are all of the missteps or all of the
confusions the money spent in the wrong
way are these mistakes missteps or are
they intentional I have a feeling you
know which one I think uh we're also
going to talk about what they've done
with Ukraine and now what they're doing
with Iran on unloading a lot of money to
them about six Bill uh and the general
lunacy of the Dems and the ineptitude of
the Republicans and the theme really if
I was to tie it all together something
from the Waf you will owe nothing and
you will be happy
perhaps we can stop them before we get
to all that let me talk to you guys
about Birch gold guys Congress once
again allowed itself to be pushed into
appeasing the administration and raising
the debt ceiling for the 79th time
Paving the way for continued Reckless
spending and further devaluation of the
dollar as our national debt continues to
Skyrocket how are you protecting your
savings times like this are a great
reminder to diversify a portion of your
savings into gold and you can do that
with the help of Birch gold here's the
easiest way to do it Birch gold will
help you convert an existing Ira or 401K
into an IRA in Gold you don't pay a
penny out of pocket as bricks that's
Brazil Russia India China and South
Africa band together against the dollar
more and more central banks are
diversifying and you know what they're
buying you guessed it gold follow their
lead visit vertical.com Dave for your
free info kit on gold there's no
obligation just information they've got
an A plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau and thousands of happy
customers Birch gold can help you
protect your savings too visit
birchgold.com Dave birchgold.com Dave
and now back to me okay so again I'm
gonna link the Maui fires and the
response Ukraine and the response Iran
and the response and a couple other
things and the response which leads us
now all to this uh potential impeachment
of Joe Biden although they don't have
the Senate so it probably ain't gonna
happen but we'll talk about that too I'm
going to link all these things together
today but I want to back up a little bit
uh and review what happened in Maui in
the first place this is from Fox News
authorities said the catastrophic
wildfires that slept that swept through
lahania claimed at least 115 lives
making it the deadliest wildfire in the
U.S in more than a century officials
have publicly publicly released the
identities of 50 people who were found
dead and five others were identified but
their names have not been released
because next of kin have not yet been
notified the remaining dead are on
identified of the living 12 000 Town
residents are now staying in hotels and
short-term vacation rentals as the Biden
Administration and Hawaii officials lead
recovery efforts rebuilding is expected
to take years and cost billions
in the immediate aftermath of the fire
more than one thousand people were
believed to be missing based on reports
from family friends or acquaintances
officials narrowed that list down to 388
who were credibly considered missing and
released that list last week okay you
will see why I am bringing this up again
of course in and of itself it's worth
bringing up again because it was it was
a horrific tragedy on American soil yes
uh Hawaii is American soil we have had a
really bad tracker as of late uh when it
comes to the federal government helping
people in times of need just look at
East Palestine and Tulsi gabbard who is
the former congresswoman from Hawaii no
longer a Democrat no longer a
congresswoman she went on Joe Rogan a
couple days ago to talk about what the
administration's reaction and response
has been to the residents of Hawaii
it's happened two or three times now
where the Pentagon has said oh we
miscalculated how much money we had set
aside for Ukraine so we have an extra 4
billion to send now that we didn't know
we had and this has happened a few times
Secretary of State Tony blinken went to
Kiev yesterday promising hey we're going
to give you another billion now and this
is the thing when I was out there in
Maui
person after person was like Tulsi
tell me what would happen if we started
to call ourselves Ukraine you think they
would give us some money then to take
care of our families to put to fix our
roofs you know that have been torn up by
the hurricane winds that came through to
make sure we have clean water to drink
you think they might pay attention to us
then and then the and then FEMA comes
out the FEMA director comes out and does
this press conference I think it was at
the White House and she says well
someone said well what are you doing for
Maui she's like oh
we're giving a one-time 700 dollar
payment to everybody who's been impacted
by the Wildfire a one-time 700 payment
it's insane Hawaii has the highest cost
of living in the entire country the
entire country and how freaking
insulting is it to have the represent
the lead Disaster Response administrator
from the Biden Administration stand
there and proudly say hey we're giving
everybody one seven hundred dollar
payment
it's insane palsy who's pretty even
keeled I mean she is pissed and rightly
so and the people of Maui are pissed and
rightly so and you can see she's linking
that something that has become I think
pretty uh a pretty consistent theme
amongst many Americans these days what
is our government doing for us while it
seemingly is doing an awful lot for the
people of Ukraine and people of all over
the world now people might have problems
all over the world is it always on us to
help them that's one question and can we
always help everybody should we always
help everybody and are we doing it at
the expense of our own citizens and
she's also bringing up a really
interesting point and we covered it I
think it was back in July it has
happened more than once where there was
an accounting error remember that one
that she's referencing there was an
accounting error and the statement
Department was like oh we actually
didn't give them it was we were supposed
to give them an extra four bill but
we're giving these residents 700
each so what really is going on in
Hawaii right now Rogan continued
bro what's going on in Maui right now
it's so sad what did they say what's
going on they're trying to take the
land yep the state is trying to
take the land the governor came out
right after the tragedy saying we're
looking to see if we can acquire the
land to build a memorial no imagine all
these and then also you know what they
got from the Biden Administration a
one-time payment of 700. and all the
money we send to Ukraine not just that
we talked about it on the podcast the
amount of money would cost to rebuild
all those homes that burnt is 5 billion
and the amount that they accidentally
oversent to Ukraine was six billion hell
no accident right and accidentally
accidentally sent him six Bill once I
think there was another four Bill once
uh you get the point we seemingly always
have our Eye Off the Ball why is it that
our federal government refuses to help
Americans and wants to help everybody
else have a little bit more on this from
the daily wire uh responding to what Joe
Rogan said Rogan was responding to a
news clip of green who told Hawaii's
khon2 news about his plans for
preserving lahanya I'm already looking
for ways for the state to acquire that
land so we can put into Workforce
housing we can put it back into families
or make it open spaces in perpetuity as
a memorial for the people who were lost
green later clarified that the goal was
to prevent wealthy people from overseas
from coming in and snapping up the land
which was why he had suggested the state
should take it and preserve it first
look whether the intention is to stop
foreigners from buying that land or
whatever the intention is the average
person in Maui is is getting the shaft
right now more and more people are
realizing it and it's worth it even
though Hawaii is not part of Mainland
America it is worth it as Americans to
understand what our federal government
is doing to our fellow citizens but it's
not just Hawaii that there is this
bizarre situation where the government
doesn't want to help Americans and wants
to help other people the big one of
these of course is Ukraine so we covered
the story yesterday about how uh Jake
Tapper had Secretary of State Anthony
blinken on and they were very upset Jake
wanted to know if there should be any
repercussions for Elon Musk because he
wasn't letting the United States do the
government do whatever it wanted with
starlink related to the ward Elon
happens to be a bit more of an
isolationist doesn't want to go into
World War III he's made that point very
clear well yesterday was the all-in
podcast Summit
they brought Elon in via Skype to
explain a bit more about his thinking
when it came to letting the government
use starlink or not use starling
at the time this happened the uh
reaching around you uh
um was actually turned off now the
reason was turned off was absolutely was
because the United States has sanctions
against Russia
um and we're not allowed to actually and
that includes Crimea in the sanctions
and we're not allowed to actually turn
on
um
sure we did not have for years ago so
so so basically the uh
look at you know Ukraine they didn't
give us any advanced warning or heads up
or anything
um where we just got the these sort of
uh
urgent calls from the Ukrainian
government saying that we needed to turn
on Pioneer it's like in the middle of
the night and we're like what are you
talking about you know are you lost
what's it for
um
you know and then
you know we're basically
um figuring out that this was
kind of like a Pearl Harbor time attack
on
um this Festival
on the Russian Festival so they're
really asking us for to really
practically take part in a major Act of
War
um
and um
you know what we certainly have huge of
support for the cleaning of it um the
Ukrainian government is not in charge
U.S uh
people or companies
it's the last line it's the line that
the people applauded for right he's
saying he's saying he he says we we
support the Ukrainian people but they're
not in charge of America the question is
who is in charge of America at this
point because America uh as a government
the American government doesn't seem to
care much about the American people and
they want to force private citizens to
use their own technology as they see fit
and he did not want to create a Pearl
Harbor uh situation so let's continue so
we've been to Maui we've been to Ukraine
uh let let's now talk about what's going
on with Iran we've got some info here
from Fox News the Biden Administration
has struck a deal with Iran to swap
prisoners and release six billion
dollars in Frozen Iranian funds per the
deal Iran will release five American
citizens detained in Iran and the U.S
release five Iranian citizens being held
in the U.S Secretary of State Anthony
blinken signed off on the deal late last
week but Congress was not notified of
the decision until Monday the Monday the
22nd anniversary of the 9 11 terrorist
attacks according to the notification
which was attained obtained by the AP
National Security Council spokesperson
Adrian Watson said secretary blinken
undertook a procedural step last week to
ensure Iranian funds could move from one
restricted account to another and remain
restricted to humanitarian trade ah okay
so these funds are being released and
they're supposed to be for humanitarian
purposes now there's also this issue
about this being done on 9 11 when it is
well known that Iran is the number one
state sponsor of terrorism throughout
the world so doing it on 9 11 but again
our government just does everything it's
almost it's so incredible that it has to
be by Design everything they seemingly
do oh your village burned down your city
burned down your house burned down
here's a 700 check we're given six Bill
to the ukrainians oh you as a private
citizen didn't give us the technology
you want we're going to suddenly look
into all of your businesses oh three
thousand people died in the worst
terrorist attack on American soil on the
anniversary of that thing we're going to
release six billion dollars to the
number one state sponsor of terrorism
it's incredible what they do but anyway
the whole point of this was that we were
releasing this money so it would be used
for humanitarian purposes
well here's the Iranian president uh on
what they plan on doing with that money
do you believe you have the right to use
that money in any way that you see fit
this money belongs to the Islamic
Republic of Iran and naturally we will
decide the Islamic Republic of Iran will
decide to expand it wherever we need it
how to spend our money of course it is
under the authority of the Islamic
Republic of Iran
so if I hear you clearly that it will be
used for more than humanitarian purposes
in your views
I don't know how often I'm going to say
it on this show I don't know that I've
ever said it before but like I kind of
agree with the president yeah we got the
cash we're gonna do whatever we want
with it and it's so it's such a perfect
example of everything that our
government does we cut deals with people
environmental climate deals nuclear
deals cash deals and then whatever
happens happen we signed a piece of
paper you said you aren't going to do
anything bad with any of this stuff like
obviously they got the sixth Bill and
they can say you know oh well anything
counts as humanitarian sure if we're
going to put 4 billion of that into
missiles inter ballistic missiles that
intercontinental ballistic missiles that
can you know go over to London well you
know it was for the behalf of our people
ah so where does this all lead us well
one day after we released the sixth Bill
to Iran Uh Kevin McCarthy has officially
announced an inquiry into impeaching Joe
Biden over his corrupt overseas business
dealings on behalf of his son the artist
and crack smoker Hunter Biden uh here is
Kevin McCarthy announcing the inquiry
that's why today
I am directing our house committee to
open a formal impeachment inquiry into
President Joe Biden
this logical Next Step will give our
committees the full power to gather all
the facts
and answers for the American public
that's exactly what we want to know
the answers I believe the president
would want to answer these questions and
allegations okay so let me just say
broadly speaking we know that the
Democrats have the Senate and also have
the VP if there was ever a tie if it
came to something like that so Joe Biden
is not going to step down because of an
impeachment right he's not going to be
impeached and have to leave the office
of the presidency uh however what this
could do I think is there's a couple
things I think you could argue one you
could argue that so many of us let's say
on the in the online world you guys that
get your news not from mainstream media
but you get it here and and other
podcasts like this and that sort of
thing uh you've been hearing about the
hunter Biden laptop you've been hearing
about the 10 to the big guy and all of
those things and it smells like a rat
right but this has only existed in our
little bubble you hear about it now on
Twitter because Elon has made it more of
a a free speech Zone but you're not
hearing about this on CNN or on Facebook
probably or wherever they can still
censor things so on one hand I think you
can argue McCarthy's doing the right
thing here because just by going for the
impeachment inquiry whether it leads to
impeachment or not and it will not
you're shining a light on it so more and
more people will have to pay attention
to the corruption So to that end I think
it makes sense the part of course that
doesn't make sense if you're just
looking at it purely in a functional way
is they just simply will never have the
numbers because they don't have the
Senate to make it happen but one of the
things that the media is going to do
very heavily is try to completely
dismiss this thing and just say there's
absolutely nothing here it's the crazy
radical matter Republicans and all that
when we know how did Joe Biden become so
rich being a public servant for all of
these years why did Hunter Biden have a
job for 80 grand a month working at a
Ukrainian energy when he was a crack
smoking porn addict like any of these
things and there's a whole bunch more we
have emails talking about the 10 and
everything else okay
but the media is going to go out of its
way to hide this thing this is
Congressman Scott Perry from
Pennsylvania a republican explaining
exactly why the Republicans are doing
what they're doing yes ma'am so what
actual evidence do you have as opposed
to allegations to show to the American
public that would Merit an actual
impeachment inquiry of Joe Biden and
prove that today isn't just about some
of you oh I don't know many people
McCarthy for the sake of enacting
political Revenge this isn't about
political Revenge we have the bank
accounts we can see ma'am you can see
that the homes that the vines own can't
be afforded on a congressional or Senate
salary you also understand that it's not
normal for family members to receive
millions of dollars from overseas
interests those things aren't normal
that's not normal to have 20 shell
Country Companies these things are not
normal and it alludes to not only just
widespread corruption but money
laundering if not influence pedaling
itself and we also have the president
the vice president at the time on record
saying that the prosecutor was fine well
son of a the prosecutor was fired
right because the prosecutor was going
after the the company that his son was
working on that's what we have if you
can't see that if you want if you're
that blind look I'll turn it over to the
attorneys people can't see that they
think it's political because you don't
report on it yeah I don't know who that
reporter was but like oh the people
don't see that yeah he's right you guys
don't report on it it's a isn't doesn't
it feel like the whole thing is like
bursting forth right now and I don't
know how the machine always stays one
step ahead but it will on this thing too
but it's like there are the wire
transfers the Ukrainian prosecutor who
got fired right who has uh Perry just
pointed out he was looking in to the
Biden family
Phoenix has given me some information on
the Fly here uh he's giving me there
below is a summary of the Third Bank
records memorandum the full memorandum
can be found here committee staff is
releasing payments from Russia
Kazakhstan and Ukraine that occurred
during Joe Biden's vice presidency the
committee now has identified over 20
million in payments from foreign sources
to the Buy family and their business
associate sorry if I butchered that a
little bit but okay so they have over 20
million dollars in wiring funds to the
Biden family over the years that he was
vice president why his son was a crack
addict working at an energy company did
it have anything to do with the fact
that his dad was the vice president so
there's money laundering there's undue
influence there's a whole bunch of stuff
here but you know if you're a reporter
oh it just seems like retribution you
Republicans are pouncing on everything
here's a journalist who got John
fetterman out of the mental institution
to respond to the whole thing
we'll see about this news that speaker
McCarthy has formally launched an
impeachment in person oh my God really
oh my gosh you know oh it's devastating
don't do it please don't do it oh no oh
no
the fact that anyone voted for him like
we deserve whatever we're getting right
now we really do with with Joe Biden as
president and the rest of this clown car
of Democrats and and mostly ineffectual
Republicans maybe we deserve all of this
stuff like that guy and also the AIDS
for all of these people that push them
along and pulled them along and we've
got to go and oh don't let fetterman
talk and all right whatever Chuck
Schumer uh well he's uh very upset about
the impeachment this is more about the
mean Republicans here you have a group
of Republicans not all but too many who
are off the deep end we have a
Republican senator who's holding up all
our military appointments and now we
have a group of Republicans and McCarthy
seems to let him go along that want to
go through the absurdity of impeaching a
president when we have so many other
things we have to get done
it's irony completely dead the absurdity
of of impeaching a president we have
other things to get done you morons did
it twice one time when he was on the way
out and your Mo and you mostly were
impeaching him for things that Joe Biden
did
but here's Schumer way back when when
Trump was being impeached this is a time
of emergency
McConnell claims he needs unanimous
consent the agreement of all hundred
Senators but it's not so
I've asked him to call the Senate back
all he needs is my agreement I'm still
minority leader
and his agreement he's majority leader
and we could come back ASAP
and vote to convict Donald Trump and get
him out of office now before any further
damage is done
who's off the deep end again I mean oh
my God
but look Republicans whether you think
it can work or not as I said it shines
some light it probably doesn't get
through the Senate you can talk about
all the strategy and and all of that
stuff there obviously is legitimate
corruption here with the Biden
Administration like like serious legit
stuff I think that is you cannot argue
that although they will argue it and
mostly censor you if you argue it and
you know call you a racist or something
like that but the real corruption here
uh which not only is the Biden family is
coming directly out of the DNC and the
mainstream media and all of their
cohorts so the other guy running for
president as a Democrat as you know is
RFK Jr and every time he says something
that makes sense or he gets some
traction or his numbers go up in the
polls the Democrats are doing everything
they can to take this guy out including
changing the rules in real time about
how their primary process works this is
RFK Jr on the Tim Dillon podcast
explaining how the Democrats right now
are going out of their way to rig their
own primary
one of the things they've done is
they've made it so that
um any vote that I get in Iowa or New
Hampshire
will account for Biden
and that and they're trying to do the
same thing now in Georgia they're trying
how are they doing that well they're
passing a rule that if you
any candidate who steps into the state
of New Hampshire Iowa to campaign
um we'll lose all their delegates
and
um and so I've campaigned in both States
so I lose their delegates but now what
they're trying to do is is and they
we're going to know on September 14th
what they actually do it
is they're trying to pass another rule
that if you step foot in New Hampshire
or Iowa
that any vote you get in New in Georgia
which is a big big delicate State
um we'll also
account for the president and not for
um you know so they're basically
disenfranchising everybody in those
States so there's no campaign and
they're talking about
this idea of making myself and Marianne
Williamson as the other Democratic
candidate to pay for all the primaries
ourselves you really need to understand
how corrupt the Democrats are just ask
Bernie Sanders about it one day
um the idea that if you step foot in one
of these places Iowa or New Hampshire
your your candidacy is basically a race
now you go well how does that make sense
why would they do that well they are
doing it because they know that Joe
Biden because of name recognition and
being the incumbent he doesn't have to
run last time he ran a basement campaign
we all know that he barely went anywhere
so RFK he wants to be out there Marianne
Williams and no one's going to vote for
her but she wants to be out there they
want to be on the ground meeting people
drumming up Grassroots support that's
what you're supposed to do as a
candidate and the DNC the the party
itself is saying if you show up in this
state if you share your ideas with our
voters we will disqualify and the crazy
part was the Georgia thing so it's one
thing they're saying if you show up in
Iowa your Iowa votes aren't going to
count and if you show up in New
Hampshire your New Hampshire boats
aren't count now they're trying to pass
this thing if you show up in either one
of those places your Georgia votes
aren't going to count these people are
so
freaking corrupt and you will not hear
about this on MSNBC and you will not
hear about it on CNN or in Washington
Post to the New York Times or anywhere
else RFK explained it uh just a bit more
and I thought he unpacks it in a nice
way it's worth reiterating DNC does not
want a primary
they're effectively disenfranchising the
Democratic voters from having any choice
and who becomes the Democratic nominee
so two of the things they've done today
they've made rules that if any candidate
since foot in the state of Iowa or since
put in the state of New Hampshire that
none of the votes that are cast for that
candidate will be tallied in other words
any delegate that I win in New Hampshire
or Iowa would go instead to the
president and now they're trying to
change it so that if I camp in New
Hampshire that none of the votes cast
for me in Georgia will count that's
significant because it's hard to win the
nomination without Georgia if you add up
all the super delegates that they
control and all of the automatic
delegates that just go to the party and
go to the president I would have to win
almost 80 percent of all of the states
in order to beat President Biden even if
he only wins 20 percent you know we live
at a time in American history when a lot
of Americans think and that democracy is
broken that the political system is
rigged and that there's not really any
democracy and unfortunately the DNC is
taking a lot of steps that that confirm
that Outlook you know you guys know I
often say you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
you can say what you want about the
Republicans but when the Republicans had
their Insurgent candidate in 2016 and
2015 actually running Donald Trump they
the RNC itself did not do any tricks to
stop him they had candidates that went
up there and tried to beat him and he
took out Marco Rubio and he took out
Chris Christie and Jeb and everybody
else but the the Machinery of the party
they went along with what the Republican
base wanted the DNC whether you think
RFK could actually beat Joe Biden or not
like he probably can't just because of
name recognition alone and the power of
the presidency and incumbency and all
that but the machine itself is going out
of its way to say screw you Democrats
the dncd stands for Democrat they don't
like their own voters and they don't
respect their own voters so you really
need to understand this like this move
by the Democrats against RFK it's the
tip of the iceberg because if they're
coming for your election and upending
that then at that point what can't they
do to you they can pretty much do
anything they can come for your
Constitution they can come for your
freedom they can come for your property
and as Klaus Schwab over the wef often
likes to say you will own nothing and be
happy so Chuck Schumer who has gone off
the deep end
I would like to offer you a mirror and I
would also like to offer one to the
governor of New Mexico because you know
this story there was this shooting in
New Mexico and then a governor Lucian
Grisha lujin Rich Grisham
she basically said she can suspend the
Constitution that people can't have
people can't carry their guns and blah
blah blah it's it's so insane it's like
how do I even have to tell this story
here she is trying to defend her
decision you took a look to the
Constitution isn't it unconstitutional
to say you cannot exercise your your
carry license with one exception and
that is if there's an emergency and I've
declared an emergency for a temporary
amount of time I can invoke additional
Powers no constitutional right in my
view including my oath
is intended to be absolute there are
restrictions on Free Speech there are
restrictions on my freedoms in this
emergency
this 11 year old and all these parents
who have lost all these children they
deserve my attention to have the debate
about whether or not in an emergency we
can create a safer environment because
what about their constitutional rights I
took an oath to uphold those two and if
we ignored this growing problem without
being bold I've said to every other New
Mexican your rights are subrogated to
theirs and they are not in my view
you're talking about crimes there are
already laws against the crimes so how
are their rights but but again if I'm
unsafe
who's standing up for that right
this woman is absolutely incredible like
that guy was an actual journalist there
are laws against those things lady right
you're not allowed to shoot people we
already have love so you can't suspend
constitutionally guaranteed
constitutionally protected rights for an
emergency she actually sounds like
Palpatine in the prequels right I love
democracy these Powers you've granted me
I shall put down when the emergencies
ended
by the U.S Obi-Wan Kenobi how that
worked out not well not well anyway here
she is continuing to defend her let's
just say not so strong legal footing on
suspending one of our constitutionally
guaranteed rights but we also have
Governor the constitution of the of New
Mexico and the Constitution of the
United States and you're an attorney do
you think you're on solid constitutional
ground here
well um we're gonna see I mean look I
wouldn't do it if I didn't think I had
the right I have the right where is the
right where is the state of New Mexico
public health it's a suspension it's not
a ban and we'll see what all of these
Court actions do it's a suspension not a
man it's just like this temporary thing
like two weeks to stop the spread oh
Fourth Amendment right to peaceably
assemble oh well for two years we kind
of didn't have that now as I pointed out
yesterday the part the like cynical
version of all of this is she can get
away with anything unless they stop her
from getting away with it we can have
guaranteed rights but they only work the
laws that we have only work if we defend
them but if enough people don't defend
that oh well they told us to stay in our
house again they told us to wear masks
again they told us we can't have guns
again like it only works if we believe
in the system right that was a line from
uh that's Padme in the prequels also
um but this is what they are doing and
guys guess what it's not just happening
in America this is a this is a I would
say a broad left-wing agenda that is
happening all over the globe right now
so let's go to Canada which used to be a
fairly peaceful type of country it was
cold up there and they were funny and
they liked poutine but they didn't uh
they didn't make waves that all changed
obviously with kovid and now Justin
Trudeau who Jordan Peterson often says
the Man simply cannot say one statement
of Truth okay he has brought in a new
Chief Public Health officer his name is
Teresa Tam uh he is also a woman
I can't take it
we need to start we see we were going to
have booze back there when we redesigned
the studio and I I guess really the
reason I couldn't do it I had originally
said well if I go on all these cable do
shows it's like if we have booze behind
me the show doesn't look serious or
something it's not professional but
really I think the reason was I'd be
getting up every five minutes just to be
drinking when I was talking about these
people anyway this this man dressed up
as a woman is now the chief what is it
the chief Public Health officer in
Canada and he wants to bring back masks
this is literally yesterday
just as a follow-up I'm sorry to cut you
off but I just wanted to take note
you're you're all masking which is level
UVC of course but most government
ministers are are not now most MPS are
not most people on the street are not
masking is is there any specific
guidance on that going forward at this
point
yes Theresa Tam so um it is a layer of
protection we hope people have developed
the Habit to be able to use masks as
needed during the respiratory Fire
season not just for covert for all the
other
um respiratory pathogens that will be
transmitted around this time so I do
think now is the time to get your mass
ready if you don't already have them
um in our own particular context we
certainly in our area there's been an
uptick in some of the covid-19
indicators for me personally there there
have been cases around
um
you know even my work colleagues so
that's one of the reasons uh why we are
wearing masks today
just to be clear a Chinese man wearing a
dress and wearing a mask is telling
people three years after this whole
charade started to continue wearing
masks even though virtually every study
says that masks don't work
do you see how I'm laying out the show
for you today almost everything coming
out of our
elected leaders and our Western
Government is designed to make a stupid
and pathetic and weak and subservient to
them I'm not really having it because I
live here in Florida but Jesus freaking
let's go back to December of 2020 and
Klaus Schwab I've uh referenced him once
or twice on the show today Cloud Schwab
of course head of the world economic
Forum this is a giant globalist
organization that basically wants a one
world government and that's why so many
of these things it starts in the United
States then it happens in UK it starts
happening in Canada et cetera Etc uh
could this all be by Design or is this
all random and coincidental well Klaus
kind of told us
we have now a window of opportunity to
create this Global reset which we all
need
sis Global reset is necessary because we
have seen that our policies which we
pursued before the Corona virus struck
us
so those policies do not create
the necessary inclusion of society
necessary for harmonious societal
development
and so do not create
sustainability of what we are doing we
have a great opportunity at this moment
like we had after World War II to have
in some way a new beginning in our
Global cooperation in globalization in
managing our Global affairs if Philip K
dick was alive he would tell you I
cannot write a science fiction story so
ridiculous this character would be so
over the top that I can't even put him
in my next Total Recall or whatever it
might be it's so insane I didn't want a
global reset did you guys want to Global
reset how are you guys doing in 2019
every I mean it was before you knew me
but besides that everything was probably
fine for you guys you were doing all
right everybody was doing just fine this
guy wants to have control of all of us
so we will live in a harmonious Society
where we will owe nothing and be happy
what do you mean no nothing and be happy
Dave they couldn't have just been
telling us that we won't own anything
and how would that make us happy well
here's a headline by Danish politician
Ida awkin in a 2016 essay for the world
economic Forum head is Klaus Schwab and
they said it you will owe nothing and be
happy I for one like owning stuff owning
stuff is good uh here's a tweet from the
wef in 2016. welcome to 20 2030 I owe
nothing have no privacy and life has
never been better look at that woman
she's so thrilled she owns a bunch of
but you won't own anything and you
will be happy so now let's really tie
this freaking thing together we've
talked about Maui we've talked about
Iran we've talked about Ukraine we've
talked about Canada all of this stuff
and nothing seems to kind of be working
right we've packaged that with them
telling us the wef telling us
that we will own nothing and be happy
could that be happening right at this
very moment uh well here's RFK Jr again
explaining what's happening uh with
housing right now in America
you're paying maybe three percent
interest now you're paying seven percent
interest
the house is three or four or five times
expensive and there's no way anyway and
then what everybody has this experience
of knowing somebody who is about to buy
a house and then somebody comes in just
before they go into escrow
somebody comes in with a cash offer and
snatches out from under them and this
this is just now a ubiquitous experience
and what's happening is not only are we
are we you know suffering inflation from
the constant Wars eight trillion dollars
on War
eight trillion dollars that we didn't
have on regime change Wars since 2002.
we're also
um you have these three giant companies
BlackRock State Street and Vanguard who
own who all own each other you know
BlackRock has 10 trillion dollars these
are all private Equity companies yeah
the biggest companies in the world and
they and they are they own
I think they own uh 88 of the s p 500s
those three companies say on 88 of the S
P 500 so they already own everything and
now they've decided
they're gonna buy every single family
home in America so
um they're on track Now to control to
own the corporate control of the 60 of
the of the single family homes in
America within six years so so you're
saying so when somebody comes in with a
cash offer it's it's usually from uh
it's an LLC with some ambiguous name a
shell Corp right and if you if you
follow the you know the bread crumbs
it'll go back to
Vanguard State Street okay so really
think about this for a second they're
telling us and have been telling us for
years you will owe nothing and be happy
now think about what's going on with
interest rates right now so before Biden
during the Trump years and even before
that we and after the housing bubble
like we had a nice I don't know about a
decade of extremely low interest rates
and what happens when there are low
interest rates when you can borrow money
cheaply let's say a two or two point
five percent well then you can put say
20 down on how house and you pay just a
little bit of interest each month and
then in essence and I I really like this
when I've bought houses over the years I
kind of like paying my mortgage because
when you have a low interest rate in
essence you're paying yourself every
month that money is going back into your
house and you're paying the bank a
little something for the the honor the
favor of lending you with the money now
the banks have gone from 2.5 3 interest
rates now we have interest rates that
are around nine percent so the average
person now if every month you have to
pay nine percent on that mortgage now
you're paying an awful lot and suddenly
you can't get that mortgage you can't
buy that house and then what happens you
have to end up renting renting you're
getting no equity you're not Building
Wealth over time owning something owning
a house or owning a car but owning
property really
it's one of the real things that I that
I think I did right in my life
financially to get things in order like
owning a house oh I own a physical thing
and I'm paying myself every month but
now if you're the average person you
can't do that and so you can see the
connection between oh if the banks raise
interest rates high enough the average
person is like I can't take out the loan
because otherwise I'm just paying the
bank every month it's a crazy amount of
money and then BlackRock and Vanguard
and these other companies come in with
these shell companies these llc's that
are kind of you just don't know who they
are and they just buy the house for cash
and now why would they buy the house or
cash either they sit there and they let
it be empty which happens or they then
allow it to be rented now there's
nothing wrong with renting in and of
itself we've all rented and at the early
part of your life renting before you've
accumulated a little cash is fine but it
sort of if you always stay as a renter
you can kind of never get into the game
so you see how the banks are connected
to exactly what BlackRock is doing so
okay again let's do the full circle
thing where did we start we started with
Maui so there are these horrific fires
and now the government comes in and what
are they trying to do well here's just a
shorter portion of that Rogan part we
showed you before they're trying to take
the land yep the state is trying
to take the land the governor came out
right after the tragedy saying we're
looking to see if we can acquire the
land to build a memorial now imagine all
these and then also you know what they
got from the bite Administration a
one-time payment of seven hundred
dollars one-time payment of 700 bucks
the government's gonna come in and take
the land BlackRock Vanguard gonna buy
all the houses do you think that's
connected to you will owe nothing and
you will be happy
so how do we do this how do we end a
show like this a rather dark depressing
show because you know I like the end
shows on a positive note well we can
complain we can Mock and we can belittle
and that kind of can be funny we can
do all that stuff or we can actually
find Solutions uh I had a response to a
tweet that went kind of viral yesterday
I want to show you the original one from
Charlie Kirk who's been on the show many
times uh Charlie wrote it would have
been much better had we done nothing in
2020 no lockdowns no masks no school
closures no stimulus no vax mandates the
damage covid did to our society was
minimal the damage our response to kobit
did was cataclysmic never again and
Charlie is quite right
So I responded and I said sounds like
strong Ron DeSantis support from Charlie
as Florida is the only state to ban
lockdowns mask mandates vaccine mandates
and gain of function research my point
guys is that although not all of our
problems can be solved by the government
that sometimes we elect some leaders who
do the right thing and we still for
however long have the ability in the
United States to move to places that are
Freer that are more in line with your
values and the Machine will always keep
coming right the machines in The Matrix
they just keep coming you can get little
wins they will always keep coming and
you have to stay alert and aware and
fight for your rights and not let the
liars and the grifters and the
people who will dupe you and take your
property and your livelihood you have to
stop them in their tracks
but there are some people and there are
some places trying to do it
second time this week I would say not
our funniest show ever did I say
anything funny today anyone
he said veteran has AIDS I said
fetterman has AIDS but I meant he has an
aid with him uh that that's the clip
that's gonna go viral Dave Rubin says
John Federman has AIDS
sorry that was kind of funny thank you
we brought it around all right we got a
cold close for you it's connected to the
cold open and we'll see everybody at
roomreport.locals.com in a moment for
the post game show adios I think we
should abolish capitalism but the how do
we do that the
it won't happen all at once but
gradually I won't be able to buy
anything
together we can be a force against our
shared enemies fascism imperialism
racism and capitalism basically all the
isms does anyone say hey can we maybe
like not be like oh we need to get rid
of all of capitalism everywhere like has
anyone expressed that I think that would
be a shortcut to achieve wider
Consciousness it's where do I get a
sandwich in your socialist Utopia
at the corner store
it's a very bizarre question sadly I was
kicked out before I could talk to anyone
less evasive thank you unfortunately
it's just how it's going to be so
that's awfully authoritarian I mean
you know we're an abolitionist
organization
but the hotel has its own kind of
procedures
we left before the abolitionists could
remove Us by force
foreign
[Music]